il ya un peu plus d'un an quand
l'économie française a été quasiment mis
à l'arrêt avec le confinement duo
qu'ovide le shift project a
immédiatement vu là l'opportunité de
réfléchir à la manière de faire repartir
cette économie d'une façon qui soit
compatible avec l'accord de paris
l'accord de paris
c'est ce traité que nous avons ratifié
et qui dit que nous devons diminuer en
pratique des émissions planétaires de 5%
par an pour éviter au climat de
connaître une dérive qui serait par trop
mortifère pour nos activités le chiffre
de project a alors démarré le plus gros
projet que nous ayons jamais porté le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française il s'agit de concevoir le
fonctionnement de l'économie
dans un monde qui se déclarent donnerait
à la bonne vitesse et ce plan vise aussi
bien l'agriculture que le bâtiment que
la construction automobile que la
culture la santé ou encore
l'administration publique
notre manière de travailler a pour
caractéristique de commencer par
regarder les ressources physiques et les
ressources humaines
avant de parler argent nous allons
considérer que ce qui est vraiment
limitant pour nous réorienter à l'avenir
c'est la quantité de ressources
physiques dont nous disposons et les
compétences dont nous disposons et à
quelle vitesse nous pouvons les acquérir
ce plan a mis au travail des centaines
de personnes et aujourd'hui nous pouvons
commencer à proposer deux premières
mesures dans plus de quinze secteurs
concernant l'économie
ce plan à intéresser beaucoup de monde
depuis que nous avons commencé à y
travailler et à en parler
en fait ils intéressent tellement de
gens que nous avons décidé de rehausser
nos ambitions par rapport à ce que nous
souhaitions faire au début et que pour
cela nous avons décidé de lancer un
appel aux entreprises
première concernée par les mesures que
nous allons proposer première source de
création d'emplois dans ce pays est
évidemment vivier important pour
l'innovation technique et
organisationnel qui va nous être
nécessaires pour relever ce défi c'est
donc aujourd'hui à ces entités que nous
nous adressons avec deux demandes
la première c'est de nous donner les
moyens de faire encore mieux que ce que
nous avons déjà commencé à faire grâce à
un financement qui lui a été recueillie
auprès
particuliers et qui a mobilisé plusieurs
milliers de personnes
et la deuxième chose que nous allons
leur demander c'est du temps pour nous
aider à discuter des propositions que
nous allons faire dont certaines
pourront probablement être vu comme un
peu révolutionnaire mais qui pour nous
sont juste la mise en cohérence des
engagements que nous avons pris pour nos
enfants et de la façon dont il faut
désormais organiser nos activités
productives
bien évidemment l'intégralité du
financement que nous récolterons auprès
de vous sera affecté à ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française
chef d'entreprise qui regardait ce
message nous comptons sur vous pour nous
aider à faire encore mieux
[Musique]